Thank you.
There's a break.
All right.
Thank you.
Right, right.
Good.
I guess I'm going to say this.
Thanks.
Thank you.
I'm going to watch you guys on YouTube.
If I need anything, give us a shot.
There you go.
If you find you need anything, give us a shot.
All right.
Thank you.
Here you go.
I understand that it's hard to keep...
Well, especially if they don't show up.
You know, supposedly this whole process is supposed to teach them, you know, personal responsibility.
We struggle with that at the community mental health center.
Okay.
So let's get started.
All right.
You're going to speak first.
No, I'm going to speak first.
But you'll be next.
Make sure the red light's on.
I don't know if you saw in your email, but we do have a new one with removable.
All right.
I need a copy of the amendment.
He's giving them to everybody.
Thank you.
saw in your email we do have a new one with removable all right i i need a copy of the amendment but he's giving him to everybody you see his hand on my phone yeah put one in the record thank you thanks so we'll open the work session for sb 422 fn and i'm going to start if that's okay to describe an amendment that mr ripple is putting forth at this point in time and i'm going to summarize by saying the goal that Representative Edwards and Senator Bradley and Senator Rosenwald came to is to make the SB 422 bill we're looking at the same as the HB 103 bill that's currently in the Senate.
And from our point of view, What that means is you have in front of you this amendment to SB 422, and you'll note that it replaces the entire bill, 422, and what it's essentially replacing it with is HB 103 with three changes.
So those changes, the first one is on page two, line 35, where the word removable has been added at the beginning of number four, removable procedentic coverage for individuals,, dot.
And that is agreed to by the department and by the sponsor of HG103.
And I think hopefully it'll be all up by all of us, but also by Senator Rosenwald and Senator Bradley.
The next change then is down on the next page, page 3, line 6, part C.
To the beginning of that exception line, the words – oh, right.
Looking at the wrong one.
The words, the beginning of that line, the words, with the exception of diagnostic and preventive services, cost sharing shall be implemented to the maximum extent allowable, dot, dot, dot.
So essentially, the cost sharing part was already in there, and this is just saying that it does not apply in the case of diagnostic and preventive services.
And then the third change relates to something that we were discussing when we did HB 103.
We did not understand what the risk corridor calculation was for which the Senate had budgeted about $2.4 million.
And so the Senate language is now incorporated into HB 103.
So that's now part of the entire bill.
Where is that deleted?
Oh, I'm sorry.
Yeah, lines.
So that is lines 17, basically all the way through 28.
Is it?
It's been removed.
No.
So, right.
So, we took out the 2.4 million from HB 103, and we had it going to general funds.
Now we've put it back in, and it's not going to general funds.
It's going to payback CMS, and we're going to hear more about exactly what that's about in just a moment here.
But first of all, I'll let Representative Shapiro have the floor.
Thank you very much and I want to thank everyone who's done endless work on this bill.
So many twists and turns and amendments and of course many people have been working on this for years and years and years.
So I just want to talk about one specific change since the idea is to make Senate Bill 422 identical to House Bill 103.
When House Bill 103 left this committee, it had a certain kind of cost sharing, certain kind of co-payment, and it's coming back in a slightly different form, so I just want to explain how that happened.
So when we went to present this bill to the Senate, Health and Human Services, some of the stakeholders had brought up the possibility of changing to, of excluding the cost sharing for diagnostic and preventative care.
And I was very reluctant to make any changes at the last minute.
I thought we had something that everyone agreed with, and I certainly didn't want to rock the boat.
However, we had a quick conversation before that Senate hearing, Representative Edwards and myself and some of the stakeholders that had brought this issue forth and I think from representative, I don't want to speak for Representative Edwards, but from what Representative Edwards said, as long as the cost sharing emulated what was in commercial plans or employer dental plans, that he was fine with it.
And so we did some quick research.
I spoke to people at Delta Dental, and they informed me that 99% of commercial plans precluded cost-sharing for diagnostic and preventative care.
So for me, the issue was that we didn't want to create obstacles to people at least getting the diagnosis and preventative care.
And of course, there's reasons to have core sharing.
I understand those reasons and the principles behind that.
The concern, of course, is that it will decrease utilization.
So I think this was a very, very good compromise in that people would still be able to get diagnosis and preventative care without having to worry about the cost sharing.
So I wanted you to know that that's how that came to be.
We weren't trying to slip a fast one on you by bringing it back in a different form and I hope that this will be agreeable to this work group and to the Finance Committee thank you any questions for Representative Shapiro thank you and I'll let other people speak to the other changes thank you I failed to remember your name I'm really bad that way, but please come forward.
Spell it out.
Brooke Belanger, B-E-L-a-n-g-e-r thank you thank you um so i can speak to the risk corridor uh that is in the language before you today the risk corridor is make sure the microphone is close enough to you that you...
Oh, I apologize.
The department added a risk corridor language to the state fiscal year 2020 managed care organization contracts.
And what this mechanism does is it protected the states against the managed care organizations experiencing a windfall as a result of decreased utilization in COVID.
So it was put in to really make sure that the state's interests were protected and that the MCOs weren't receiving unjust compensation as a result of the decline we saw in individuals receiving care.
So I'm happy to flesh that out more if needed, but I think that may serve your purpose today.
So now I understand what the risk corridor is.
That's great.
So why are we paying CMS back $2.4 million as it relates to that risk corridor?
Thank you.
So the $2.4 million is needed to complete our settlement with the federal government.
When Centene reported inflated pharmacy costs, that adjusted the risk corridor.
And so the $2.4 million will be returned to the federal government to complete that corridor, which, and as you know, the inflated cost calculations that Centene reported was what allowed the state of New Hampshire to participate in the broader Centene settlement agreement, which leads to the $21 million.
So the smaller portion, that 22.1 million, is to return to the federal government as a result of the inflated costs.
Any other questions from the committee or anybody else?
No?
Okay.
Is there anybody else that wants to speak?
Dr.
Finney, do you have any final words?
Thank you.
Those are my final words.
Now, I truly appreciate all of the work that has gone into this.
Countless hours, countless years, actually.
And so I just want to do a blanket thank you.
And, you know, the department will certainly do whatever we can to make sure that we keep moving forward that's the most important thing is there anybody else in the audience that wanted to put in their two cents no all righty thank you all very much and uh we'll close the hearing i guess i should have added that we're going to miss it at a remote in the future.
You got that.
Very efficient.
All right.
Thank you.